he's in the
fifth or sixth year i think i don't know
i lose track of the number of years of
these contracts maybe just third or
fourth year of his latest deal he does
really long deals which makes it hard to
accumulate the kind of leverage that
we've seen other quarterbacks accumulate
the shorter the better he's got three
years left on his current contract there
was an item from rob dymovsky of
espn.com on friday that looked at the
current relationship
between rogers and the packers from the
perspective of
unnamed agent unnamed scout
unnamed executive offering opinions and
i'm never a big fan for my own purposes
of trafficking in
unnamed opinion because
unless you know who it is or at least
unless you have some context as to who
it is you never quite know
what agenda the person giving the
opinion might have and this is
a corollary to the pre-draft stuff where
the anonymous scout
says something bad about
a prospect because the anonymous scout
is hoping that that prospect will be
there when his team picks but the one
thing that stood out to me yeah and this
is the difference in my mind between
chris anonymous opinion and anonymous
fact right
the unnamed agent
saying that
he has a client yeah and
they called me about one of my players
and said hey this is where we are now
and until we get something big done hint
hint we don't have any cap space and
that's something big hint hint is number
12. running into the end zone and
sticking the ball over the goal line and
throwing the ball down the field in the
divisional round win over the la rams
that's the something big they need to do
and the irony there is chris they had
the absolute right we brought this up a
week or so ago and i've since gotten the
contract language they have the absolute
right to convert salary ratio bonus etc
into a signing bonus that would give
them a lower cap number this year the
problem is it makes it harder next year
if next year is the year when they would
decide to trade and it makes it more of
a cap charge because it all accelerates
right
into next year's cap if they kick the
can now so they haven't done it and i
don't know what you can do what what do
you do how do you create cap space
without pushing it into future years
that would then come due if you decide
after this year you want to move on i
think that's that's why the packers are
currently stuck right now no i don't
think mark murphy wants to be in a
position where if i decide after this
season i'm moving to jordan love i'm
taking this gigantic cap hit that keeps
us from doing business no man you know
probably not that's why i brought it up
last week i think it was tuesday right
because i was watching the aaron rodgers
jeopardy on monday going wait and
started to think about some of these
things and we're just thinking about
football and you know i know that you of
course we all know green bay is a little
bit of an a at the bottom of the league
as far as salary cap their situation
anything like that
but
yeah i mean you've always said from the
start yeah they can convert that money
and make you know make it into a signing
bonus but of course yes it's gonna cost
more down the road right all right so
what's next hey let's renegotiate the
contract
oh yeah really why
what's in it for me i don't understand
oh ho so you guys want to make it easier
to move on for me or i i don't know what
you're trying to do are you going to
support me this year is this sort of
support next year or for the other
quarterback two years down the road so i
mean again renegotiate sure it might
help the team out either way but what i
want to say to green bay is renegotiate
i mean his court his court contract is
so quarterback friendly it's disgusting
it doesn't get any easier
he's been so nice it's ridiculous he's
what what is he right now the eighth the
eighth the sixth the fifth highest paid
quarterback in football very manageable
tied with jared goff right right drop
the mic and let's end the show see you
later okay so i yes there this is on
them they got to figure it out and aaron
rodgers with this situation does have a
little power here to see where his
future goes a little bit
and this is the core of it we've said it
a few times and every once in a while
i see what others are writing or i catch
wind of what others are saying and
i i i don't know how
widespread this
thought is but in my mind chris it's a
very very simple proposition the packers
are now in the year to year phase of the
aaron rodgers contract where they truly
can say after 2021 where are we do we
continue do we not continue oh okay we
continue after 2022 where are we do we
continue do we not continue that's where
they are on the back end of this deal
because it was a long-term deal
tacked onto the end of the last
long-term deal that he did back in 2013.
rogers wants and this is something i
reported right after he gave us all that
curveball following the nfc championship
loss to the buccaneers where
he seemed to be talking like a guy who
may not be back this year he wants
commitment not necessarily money
but commitment he wants to be tied to
the team
so he doesn't have to spend all of 2021
every practice every game
every post game
every moment wondering when this season
ends is this the year that they say
we're activating the jordan love plan
and
as i've said i think mark murphy is far
more of a genius than we're giving him
credit for
he's found a way
to put aaron rodgers in what i call the
sweet spot of pissed off where he's mad
enough to go out and be the mvp but he's
not so mad that he's ready to say to the
packers screw you i'm out of here after
this season maybe he will be but i think
that's where murphy's trying to keep him
and the fact that they haven't done
anything with his contract and they
haven't exercised their absolute
privilege to reduce his cap number this
year but make it more expensive next
year from a cap standpoint to move on
make it trickier to move on next year
from a cap standpoint i feel like
murphy's trying to keep him in that
range of
just pissed off enough to be great but
not so pissed off that he wants to leave
well yeah i mean yes
listen i i hear you there i do i i don't
think aaron rodgers needs mark murphy
either way to be that i don't think it
needs it i think he wants to be great no
matter what did last year piss him off
yeah of course it did i'm sure you know
yeah i mean did it motivate him i i
agree with you there there's something
to that there's no doubt it was a second
year in that offense everything like
that people were kind of starting to
clamor and and doubt him a little bit so
all that led to aaron rodgers being on
his a game week after week after week
but like
i i mean i don't know i mean
i i just sit here with all the the way
you just explained it okay yeah what
what are they gonna do all right so
you're talking about the salary cap
thing and the the converting into the
signing bonus they don't want to do that
because like you've said that's going to
it's going to count against them
down the road right the next few years
so what's the next it ties him it ties
him to the packers right two years as a
practical matter if they max out if they
max out the cap space this year by
shrinking his cap number and giving him
a huge signing bonus and converting and
moving and bumping it makes it it makes
it much harder
a year from now to say we're going to
trade him and we're going forward jordan
i think that's the practical impediment
if they would do it right right so that
i mean that that speaks volumes i mean
so they didn't do that
they didn't do that so there you go i
don't know aaron rodgers of course has
no choice there they could do that but
it would again maybe give him what he
wants to go or hey i got a little more
security here with the team they are
maybe tied with me in the next year or
two but then the next option is what
oh
renegotiate
and what you give me a little bit more
money up front even you know okay i'm a
hundred millionaire already you're gonna
give me more money up front to what make
my future
you know
more undecided and i have no idea what's
going to go on or if i'm going to be
here or anything like that that's not
going to happen that's not going to
happen there's just no way i i at least
i don't i don't think of it that way i
mean i don't know just the more we sit
here and the more this off season goes
on the more i just think this is headed
towards like we talked about a little
last week it's like brady in new england
this is gonna be the same thing there's
gonna be rogers in green bay green bay
hasn't done enough quite to support them
their team's in a different spot
thinking about going a different
direction and he's just gonna go okay
i'll see you later i'm gonna go try to
end my career somewhere else and win a
super bowl somewhere else i really feel
like we're headed in that direction with
these two
and let's remember they pulled the pin
on this grenade nearly a year ago when
they moved up at the bottom of round one
gave up a fourth round pick packaged it
with their first round pick went up
several spots to draft a quarterback a
quarterback at a time when aaron rodgers
was the exact opposite of brett favre
they drafted rogers in 2005 because
farve was four years into his annual
will i or won't i retire schtick rogers
consistently has said
green bay is where i want to stay i want
to play into my 40s and i want to play
my entire career with green bay he had
given them no reason whatsoever to be
thinking about a succession plan now
chris i do recall when we did your
quarterback rankings
last year yeah and correct me if i'm raw
no you're i recall you detecting some
slippage right in 2019. okay that
slippage he was reversed last year well
yes i mean he went from the greatest
thing i've ever seen to like the
slightly not the greatest thing i've
ever seen that's what i was talking
about
i was just saying there's a little
slippage in rogers like where yes he
wasn't quite as explosive running out of
the pocket and doing things like that to
where
there was some plays where you go oh we
got shoelace tackled ooh two three years
ago that wouldn't have happened that he
would have ran away from that guy you
know yeah okay just some natural but not
like concerning not concerning like no
doubt in my mind that it was still you
know top three top five quarterback and
football type of play and type of player
still and then yes i mean of course last
year was was phenomenal but i mean mike
i don't know i mean where does this go
if you're aaron rodgers are you up for
that are you up for renegotiating your
contract and and making it easier for
green bay to get away from you at some
point i i don't know what no yeah no
right i want i don't necessarily want
more money i want commitment that's what
i want that's why he should be
on board with the idea of a simple
restructuring that would give him
the large majority of his 2021
compensation and they've already paid
him a 6.8 million dollar roster bonus
that ship has sailed that could have
been converted now there's a 14.7
million dollar base salary that could be
converted all but 1.075 million of it
and max out caps based this year and get
some help around him but it ties the two
sides together more likely for the next
two seasons that's why he's saying my
future is undecided my future is not
resolved my future is a beautiful
mystery he's smart enough to know
the way these contracts work and the
flexibility the teams
like to have because they want to be
able to use it if they choose to do so
and this all goes back to last year we
never have gotten any real clarity from
the green bay packers think about it no
nearly a year has gone by why in the f
pardon me on a monday morning did they
get jordan love in the first round of
the draft last year what were they
thinking chris
when
you got a good thing going with aaron
rodgers you've got several more solid
seasons of aaron rodgers as your
starting quarterback you got to the nfc
championship you've got clear needs and
instead of addressing them in round one
you give up a fourth round pick to move
up to get a guy that is either going to
supplant aaron rodgers at some point or
ultimately be a wasted pick there's no
middle ground he's either going to take
over for aaron rodgers before rogers is
ready to go or he's going to be a wasted
first round and fourth round pick
there's nothing else i i i listen that
that's the million-dollar question you
know added to the the fact of
you know doing
nothing really for the team while you're
in the super bowl window and you know
again here we are we're talking about
renegotiating the contract and hey aaron
carry us on the field and now the
season's over can you carry us off the
field because we got no money to figure
out how to balance our books and hey
here we are once again in free agency
and we haven't jumped we haven't done
jack diddley squat once again this year
i mean nothing nothing it's just like oh
don't worry it's don't worry erin you'll
come back and carry us don't worry and
then we'll screw you over and we'll find
another way to do something i don't know
but like yes i don't know mike green bay
is one of those teams of course they've
been very successful they have a formula
in which they wait the way they do
things whether it's lack of spending on
free agency like you and i have talked
about before you know they want to build
through the draft they like to keep
their own
you know i don't know but it probably
said that it was time for them to draft
a quarterback in a lot of ways listen
like i was watching i want to say this
was dan graziano the other day on on tv
just a little segment i was watching
where he was a little talking about this
and just talking about how hey green bay
has been successful for the last 20
years because of this formula and he's
right and i agree with them but
have they really
have they really like let's let's really
i know it's been relevant and in the
playoffs but they've had two of the five
greatest quarterbacks in the history of
the league
two of the group five greatest in the
history of the league as far as i'm
concerned and they've won one super bowl
with each i don't know if that's
necessarily like a great success rate to
me when you put it that way wait you've
had two of the all-time five greatest
quarterbacks in the history league
you've won two super bowls that tells me
you've done something else wrong and
supporting them too and i think you
certainly can make that argument you
know alongside of yeah they've been
relevant in the playoffs and all that
it's the corporate ownership angle yeah
that's good enough it's maximizing
profit you don't have to have that and
this can be counterproductive i know it
can blow up in your face right but look
at what the tampa bay buccaneers did
this year this past year the packers
would never do that yeah they would
never go all in the way the packers have
right the packers are about slow and
steady wins the race once every 20 years
yeah that's what the packers at we're
always in the race we're always in the
race
but
but we're never going to do anything
crazy right to try to win the race right
now if we do that's great chances are we
will from time to time once every 15 to
20 years but every other year
pack stadium
70-year waiting list fans are happy
not thrilled but they're happy
we're always relevant we're always on
the porch we're always near the door
and that's good enough and again we've
had that conversation with teams that
have traditional owners we've had that
conversation about the packers
which teams when they say our goal is to
win the super bowl this year really mean
it which ones are acting that way that
our goal is to win the super bowl this
year clearly last year the packers goal
was not to win the super bowl or they
wouldn't have drafted jordan love it's
that obvious yeah it's right in front of
our faces and some what happens is chris
the arden zealous fans are so wired
to support everything the team does even
if they privately are asking themselves
what the hell is the team doing that
they'll fight back with us yeah no i
know oh you don't know what you're
talking about i know what i'm talking
about you don't use two quarterbacks
that's what i'm talking about yeah so
you draft a quarterback in round one
when you have a team that's otherwise
close to being super bowl ready and you
mean to tell me that team is trying to
win the super bowl this year bullcrap
yeah bullcrap and you could really say
that about the rest of their picks to go
along with that you know they were all
like somewhat future
future looking type draft picks so where
you go okay so agreed with you i don't
know mike where does where does it go
where does this whole situation go i i
mean i i've kind of told you my thought
is just where i i feel like we're going
towards the
an end of the year separation
but
i mean i i don't know do you think
roger's going to try to renegotiate his
contract here do that i i don't expect i
don't expect i don't i don't think
anything's gonna happen right here look
i've i've used this example in the past
as it relates to
tom brady's potential exit from the nfl
i think the same thing
applies to aaron rodgers potential exit
from green bay final scene both longest
yards
paul crew
goes to pick up the football
as the warden stands there watching and
eventually paul crew brings the football
back to the warden and says stick this
in your trophy case
so
packers win the super bowl
aaron gets the lombardi and he gives it
to mark murphy and he says stick this in
your trophy case that's that's what i'm
rooting for and then the beautiful
mystery unfolds in 2022 whether he just
exits for jeopardy or something else
or plays for a different team next year
that that's that's how i you know what
do you root for root for a great story
and i can't think of a story that would
be greater than that for 20 20 years
it'd be pretty good i mean you know
like we've talked about like pittsburgh
right with like big ben and they
probably look at the the buccaneers and
all that and wait why can't we do that
defense or protect them and do all that
like
the other buccaneers effect might be
right here like i mean
don't you think
don't you think brady's probably
embolden a person like rogers in this
situation right now to look at that and
go wait i can do that i can leave
somewhere and go somewhere else and do
it i don't have to be at the same team
forever you know you won't be too
harshly judged or all that you you say
you agree with me i see your head
nodding there oh yeah oh yeah and i
think it would it would be it would be
perfect
if his path takes him to new england no
no i don't know how he and bill
belichick would coexist but my my
goodness i mean we've had that that
alternate history what happens if aaron
rodgers had been with the patriots for
the past 15 years instead of tom brady
for 20 how many more
less the same trophies would they win
yeah but yeah the idea that that you see
where the dust settles on 2021 you find
your best spot you call your shot you
continue your career in a spot where you
think that they're gonna go all in
for whatever you have left because the
last guy in the organization who's
worried about the five-year plan is the
quarterback who's on a one year at a
time plan as a practical matter and is
trying to win now and he truly is trying
to win a super bowl now because he may
not be around yeah next year so yeah i'm
i'm intrigued by that all right we're
supposed to do nfc north draft needs in
this segment now that we fully exhausted
the aaron rodgers uh do you want to kick
it down the road we can do it next
segment well let's keep is there
anything more you got on aaron rodgers
than chris no i mean i i don't think so
i think we've hit all angles i mean
unless there's something else that you
that you haven't brought up i think i
mean i'm good whatever you want to do
here
i i missed the note in the document that
we share electronically that we can kick
the nfc north draft needs to the next
segment so i apologize for the
clunkiness of the last 45 seconds
i just think that
there won't be a new contract for aaron
rodgers no right i'm with you mark
murphy will try to keep him in that
sweet spot of pissed-offedness where
he's great
but not
not over the top angry
and there's no reason to think they're
not going to be 13 and
4 or 14 and three it's still going to
take a while to get used to or something
close to that kind of excellence in the
nfc north the question is can they
navigate the playoff field can they
overcome the buccaneers can they make it
to the super bowl can they win the super
bowl and it would be beautiful if they
do
and aaron rodgers says stick in your
trophy case i know that that would just
that that would be beautiful well yeah
and how could packers fans be upset
about that if you're a packers fan if
you're a packers fan do you want four
more years with aaron rodgers and no
super bowl win or one more year and he
exits as a super bowl champion i feel
like that should be a poll question
what would you rather have
would you rather have yeah right you
want a super you want another trophy
yeah i'll take one more year and a
trophy over four more years and no
trophy any day of the week i think that
applies wouldn't that apply
i don't know that that applies to any
quarterback but you want you as a fan
you want your team to win super bowls
yes give me a super bowl i'll take it
one more year with rogers in a super
bowl i'll take it's probably a 95
poll question if we do it don't you
think i i guess i would think so i would
think more more people are going to take
that angle for sure i mean gosh it's a
super bowl lombardi trophy they're not
that easy to come by as we're seeing you
know right here anyways in the green bay
organization and i just sit here again
and just go you know this is why the
guy's the greatest of all time to me
because it's just gonna be oh hey
hey no problem we're not gonna do
anything to really improve the team for
the second year in a row you just carry
us and get us there you know and
hopefully
you know you could play
totally perfect in the nfc championship
game this time totally perfect and not
make one mistake because i know you made
one mistake on the interception which
was pass interference down the middle
but as long as that doesn't happen maybe
we can win it and maybe you can pull
like three rabbits rabbits out of your
butt while you're doing it too and
that'll help i mean that's what they ask
them to do every year and here we are 20
21 going right back to the drawing board
i know i know it's a good team but don't
ever go above and beyond green bay and
make it a great team just have the great
quarterback make your good team look
great and then you know you guys could
fall short and we can all crap on the
great quarterback for not getting them
over the top that that's what they do to
them every year and that's why green bay
pits pisses me off
you had me pondering the question there
of whether it's worse to have three
rabbits in your butt or three rockets up
your butt i'm not quite sure rockets but
but i think i think the way to word the
question is if you're a packers fan
would you rather have one more year with
rogers in a guaranteed super bowl or
four more years and a reasonable shot
each year
of winning a super bowl but no guarantee
i think that's the way to phrase yeah
that that's the tougher question
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports